un vote pour la forme ce jeudi jean
castex est venu présenter aux députés et
sénateurs les nouvelles mesures
annoncées la veille au soir par le chef
de l'état une demi heure de discours au
palais bourbon au cours de laquelle le
locataire de l'hôtel matignon a défendu
les décisions prises jusqu'à présent par
l'exécutif pour enrayer l'épidémie dans
une ambiance houleuse
ces décisions ne sont jamais faciles
elle ne sent jamais sain elles obéissent
à plusieurs exigences rechercher le
meilleur équilibre possible entre
protection et contraintes agir ni trop
tôt ni trop tard
en s'adaptant en temps réel
aux évolutions de l'épidémie le premier
ministre s'est d'ailleurs fendu d'une
véhémente sortie contre l'opposition
dans un style qu'on ne lui connaissait
pas mais la bella voyez-vous j'aurais
aimé ce matin je vous dis que vous
m'indiquer monsieur a bardé les gens
comment nous procurer davantage de doses
je vous assure que si vous aviez
formulées sur ce terrain une
préconisation opérationnel j'annonçais
ici immédiat pas que je l'adopté
mais rien au final la prestation de jean
castex n'aura guère convaincu que les
élus de son propre camp les autres ont
préféré boycotter le vote tout ça on est
out out out et on s'est mis à 8 nous
mêmes je veux dire que la majorité en
marche a choisi de s'auto démissionner
via 0 décision qui se prend ici ici
c'est une chambre d'enregistrement des
désirs du président c'est un simulacre
de démocratie
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que pour
nous ce débat là alors que décision
était prise dès hier n'a plus de sens
voilà c'est une mascarade démocratique à
laquelle il participa on a bien compris
que il y avait un orage de la nation et
qu'ensuite la majorité devait sûr je
vois que nos oppositions
finalement on pense que la démocratie
serait quelque chose de bien inutiles
devient accessoire et se contentent des
plateaux télé des déclarations
politiques
il préfère commenter critiquer
pronostiqué ce qui s'est passé la veille
prédire l'avenir quand il parle du passé
et ne pas assumer leurs responsabilités
je les envie outre les députés de la
majorité qui ont voté comme un seul
homme en faveur des propositions de
l'exécutif tout comme quelques noms
inscrits seuls les neuf élus du
rassemblement national se sont exprimés
et ce contre les mesures instaurées
l'après midi rebelote au sénat et comme
au palais bourbon
les élus de l'opposition ont refusé de
servir de faire valoir législatif le
gouvernement voulait que nous votions
sur rien à quoi bon voter
ainsi déjà tout était décidé pensons que
le sénat comme le parlement comme
l'assemblée nationale c'est pas une
chambre d'enregistrement
ce gouvernement a des pouvoirs
extrêmement étendue mais qui sont
concentrés dans une seule main celui d'
emmanuel macron qui décide de tout
président de la république doit entendre
qu'il ne peut pas seul décider pour tout
le monde dans le bunker du conseil de
défense
ce n'est plus possible qui était au
coeur de deux interventions
outre la préoccupation qui est la nôtre
sur la situation sanitaire dans le pays
c'est ce déni de démocratie qui
s'installe insidieusement aujourd'hui
dans notre pays depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de emmanuel macron et cette
pantomime puisque moi je considère que
c'est une pantomime n'est pas acceptable
dans une république dans notre pays
au final cette journée aura surtout été
une démonstration d'allégeance de la
part de la majorité à l'assemblée est
une nouvelle occasion pour les autres de
condamner l'effacement du pouvoir
législatif au profit du pouvoir
présidentiel